où j'ai foutu mes lunettes il ya deux
ans j'ai fait une vidéo sur facebook
créée n'avoir mais aujourd'hui je vais
vous parler de facebook
j'ai décidé de faire une petite mise à
jour parce que facebook a quand même
bien changé depuis
maintenant on peut dire j'aime à tout ce
qu'on veut ça n'existait pas ça avant
elles ont entraîné des pratiques assez
bizarrement ça l'ailé les gens qui
laissent un statut qui aiment leur
propre statut qui laisse un commentaire
à leur statut et qui aiment ce
commentaire vous en avez déjà vu des
gens comme ça à quoi ça sert je ne sais
pas peut-être qu'ils sont amnésiques
c'était trop bien la soirée hier un
statut j'aime au un statut c'est clair
t'as raison aux un commentaire j'aime un
autre truc mystérieux sur facebook les
gens qui mettent leur métier dans leur
nom genre kevin boulet photographe s'est
très souvent des photographes d'ailleurs
bratton explique l'utilité un jour
bientôt ce sera quoi
jean baptiste pignoux agents de
maintenance des unités de production les
unités de production
c'est ma passion sans parler des mecs
qui met officielle dans leurs noms dont
dire quoi ça c'est à dire que des gens
qui sont officielles et d'autres qui
sont officielles ou alors ils ont un
clown qui se fait passer pour eux je
sais pas bonjour telle une boule est
enchantée savannah c'est moi kévin boli
officiel un poster un il m'a découvert
un autre truc qui me perturbe sur
facebook c'est les gens qui changent de
photos de profil plusieurs fois par
semaine
pas pour mettre une nouvelle photo non
mais juste pour changer leurs rimes est
celle d'avant puis ça d'après les puis
celle d'avant avant comme ça pour
changer juste envie de poser une
question aux gens qui font ça pour quoi
ah si c'est parce qu'en non non non
awa laurie non a lancé je vois pas ce
qui est logique là dedans bon le truc
qui est bien c'est que aujourd'hui
presque tout le monde est sur facebook
et ça c'est très pratique dans le monde
du travail par exemple cyprien il faut
que tu donnes le dossier à julien
plichon oui julien pichon oui oui oui
oui oui je suis chaud bien sûr que ça
fait quand même dix ans que je suis dans
l'entreprise
ah je sais qui c'est un jeu je connais
son prénom sur sa peux même te sauver un
petit peu la vie et ses prix yahia anaïs
bouffis de la compta qui veut boire un
verre avec toi ce soir
anaïs bouffi non maintenant je suis je
suis malade ce soir je me sens pas bien
je je pensais que c'est un homme annexe
bouffi moi je lui disais bonjour
monsieur le matin voilà pas que des bons
côtés à ce que tout le monde soit sur
facebook un ma mère est sur facebook
pire la grand-mère et sur facebook peer
to peer
ma grand-mère commente mais ce statut là
j'ai dit non ah non là c'est pas
possible je peux pas laisser passer ça
j'ai pris le problème à la base famille
qu'est ce qui t'arrive là tu arrêtes ça
tout de suite hein ça te plairait que je
vais commenter pendant qu'on change sa
couche est passé pareil voilà tu arrêtes
sinon je viens la maison de retraite et
je te les branches à mais je m'en fous
n'hésitez pas à partager ma vidéo sur
facebook à rejoindre ma page et aller
sur cyprien point fr pour voir toutes
mes autres
vu un poster merde
[Musique]